remember lots of businesses in america
didn't make it through the pandemic this
one did
and this is a giant location with all
kinds of overhead
look at how big it was you're kind of a
story of survival
and i'm going across the country trying
to find people like you
so that others can learn for the next
time what you have to do
[Music]
hey mr wonderful here in wynwood miami
you know where this is center of the
arts why
because i dropped my guitar a few months
ago and i had to find a guitar tech to
fix it
and when i went on the blogs and started
searching online who's the el supremo
guitar tech in miami alex this guy that
works out of this shop
this is incredible place called wall
grace inside of it you've got
cars bars and guitars i'm not kidding
all in one building so while you're
waiting for your guitar to get fixed or
just looking at other guitars
you can have a cappuccino cruise around
some really nice ferraris
all that kind of stuff it's just a
beautiful i think display of art and
celebration of design so let's go inside
and check it out all right
[Music]
so tina you're the owner of this place
yes i'm one of the unions how many
owners are there there's
two of us so you're partners we're
partners yes
is this the only location for now it is
the only location
and what is let's call wall grace what
is it
like what was the idea of this thing so
walt grace came about
it is a song from john mayer that
inspired bill
to my partner to uh be happy
just like a husband wife thing or are
you a guy it's a boyfriend girlfriend
thing
okay but yeah that's always tricky in
business of course yes because there's
the business and then there's a
relationship yes but i think
most importantly our goal is to
keep our passion alive which is vintage
cars guitars and
coffee as you can see we're in so bars
cars guitars exactly that's what really
knocked me out when i walked in here
said what the [ __ ]
is this like that's because it really it
really is
it's it's basically bill's brain
exploded
and manifested everything here is our
passion
if it's not if it's a guitar that we
don't particularly like or even a
a beverage a cookie a muffin we won't
sell it if it's a car that
you know isn't up to our standards to
so to speak we we we would never have is
bill
a car guy like where where the car
where'd the cars come okay so
bill has always been obsessed with
vintage porsche
and vintage guitars okay so that's
clearly what's going on here because you
know
you know the old porsche ads or the
little boys just like looking into the
car
that that was bill that is bill okay so
that was his passion
he morphs it into a business there's a
lot of people interested in how
entrepreneurs
find their path because this idea
wouldn't necessarily work anywhere else
i mean it's it's a very first of all the
neighborhoods
it got a crazy vibe to it right this is
legendary in terms of art scenes in
miami the art and epicenter
it is the place to be in miami right
but then this this is a lot of retail
space you've got a lot of space here
a lot of square feet so your idea is put
this thing together
how did you get people to find out about
it what did you do it's funny because
coming him coming from an advertising
background we did not advertise at all
it was all word of mouth thankfully for
social media
it was you know people taking photos
tagging us
how many years ago was that about five
five and a half yes
okay so you have you know i have a rule
if you're not making money by the third
year
you take it behind the barn and shoot it
right so this is actually a business
right
yes it is um but it's you know one of
the things that we
we implement is we don't sell to people
we are dream facilitators this is
ultimately a passion project
so when people come into our front door
you know their mouths drop they're i
mean obviously now with our masks i
can't see the mouths dropping but i see
the sparkle in their eyes
once after they do rounds spend some out
several hours here they always tell us
how inspired they are
because of what we have here and you can
feel our vibe like everything we do
is out of passion and love there's a lot
of blood sweat and tears
here so the vision is to get them
engrossed in just the
the vibe of the place bill's passion
your passion but you got to turn it into
a business you have to actually have
revenue unless your bill where his mom
calls him a schmuck he is a schmuck
so you know we you know many kids come
in here and and
young guys who are obsessed with guitars
a couple years ago we had a young man
who
fell in love with a guitar that we named
and called gator
because of the way that it was relict
and the way that it was worn
and he could not afford it and we let
him go home with it
and for years no i mean thinking of him
gives me goosebumps and that same idea
is how we treat all our customers
so but clearly for the let's be let's be
clear to to run a business
employ people you have employees here
you got to have revenue you have to make
money are you achieving success at that
level we are
of course we still have our family to
feed and we take care of all of our guys
so you've got an online presence as well
i assume yeah
okay so you're trying to get the vibe of
this place pushed out online you're
doing
obviously more social media now right i
found out about this place through
social media that's how
nice i dropped a guitar i said i need a
great guitar tech
i went online i started seeing all these
comments about this jonesified
stuff and i said who the hell's that guy
and that's
kind of word of mouth drew me here then
i walked in here and said this
no this isn't right there's cars here
where are the guitars and you look to
the right oh
guitars and so it's it's okay
but driving the business would you say
is different now in the fifth year do
you have like a model in terms of what
you want to do to get revenue and grow
um yes i think so
i think that our you know the more we
grow
is the harder it is to i think
personally
to stay focused on why we originally
started and i think that
um we have to remind ourselves that that
despite you know
all the bills and overhead and
everything we have to pay
we still need to stay keep our focus
which is to keep the dream alive
to keep rock alike to to have investment
pieces that people
truly love and not just have to have
i think for me that is what what is
important yeah
i know this is about money and
everything and it's important
but but we don't just sell to someone
who has the money if somebody comes in
here and it's like i want the most
expensive guitar
we do not sell that to that person
because we know
that it needs to go to the right home
and to the right person
okay now give some advice to businesses
that have survived this pandemic because
clearly your business
changed last march i mean i was here in
miami this place got
shut down everything got shut down it
was a ghost town walking around here so
what did you do to survive
we had our team working from home as
with everybody
we had them pumping out social media
posts
i think to keep things alive i mean
thankfully being at home and
people being quarantined the guitars
really
just kept we kept selling everybody was
learning to play on youtube or signing
up for
guitar lessons online um so thankfully
the good
i believe that the guitar end is really
what kept us afloat
so online saved your ass base oh yes
who runs online um well we do have
our main like three uh people
we have vince um our daughter haley and
um a couple of the other guys um but
ultimately we all
like you're shooting the instruments
you're photographing them you're posting
on your site
you're pushing for traffic i mean this
is a lesson in survival that i'm trying
to talk about here because
not every business in america made it
and it seems the only ones that did make
it figured out a way to directly connect
with their customers
during a whole year when they were shut
down and those customers responded by
buying stuff that happened here
that happens with us also and you know
even just being at home and watching
people play
and and be on instagram live just as
simple as
you know making our logo shirts
reversible so that way when you're on
instagram live you can actually read our
logo um
and that you know harold played the
guitar for you and his shirt you'll see
is backwards so we did little things to
tweak and like
to keep us relevant and in
you know it's speaking in people's
mouths so i do feel the community is
opening up a little bit now things are
starting to happen
vaccines pouring through yes definitely
especially here in florida
yeah i know i know well i noticed that
but you know it's amazing it's only have
been the last month where you start to
see the foot traffic
starting to come back which is great but
what do you
what having learned that whole online
pivot
you're going to keep that business
growing right
and are you selling guitars to people
outside of the geography of miami
uh yes we actually ship over to europe
we're shipping all across the united
states
of course shipping things gets a little
tricky depending on the wood
you know what woods are allowed to leave
this the states
but we sell online uh jonathan
sells cars online as well thankfully in
this day and age everything is online
you're kind of a story of survival and
i'm going across the country trying to
find people like you
so that others can learn for the next
time what you have to do
sounds like passion you got a mission
you got a really good online business
and you have people love to work here
and you got a really crazy chicken space
i mean it's just
this is nuts it's what is all this stuff
so we got all your accessories here uh
we got strings we have cables
products to keep your guitar you know
nice and polished and clean
uh stuff your for your fretboard
replacement parts in case you need
uh some of that stuff people don't buy
all the stuff online you actually have a
business selling this out of the store
yeah people want to grab the stuff quick
you know you
and you have a gig you need pack of
strings you come grab them cables
yeah we do sell a lot of stuff and we
sell online obviously yeah
actually this whole concept is in the
face of online because
you can't experience anything like this
online that's probably why you stay in
business right
yeah and we do try to bring as much as
of this experience you know online to
our website you know we
we take photos of everything that we
sell here we take photos in that room
actually in the vintage room
we don't want to use stock photos we
want to make sure you can see the guitar
in our environment you know
so you sell it online yeah we do
something but you try and project this
vibe on your online site yeah and in
social media you know we want to make
sure that people understand what we do
here
and what we're all about and we try to
you know showcase that on our website
our social media channels on our youtube
channel as well
so yeah everything all the photos you'll
see of our guitars and amps uh we shoot
them in that room where you were earlier
uh and yeah and all the cars we shoot
them here too we want you to get the
the feel of the gallery you know you
want to see the cars with the guitars in
the background
bring you in yeah yeah remember lots of
businesses in america
didn't make it through the pandemic this
one did and this is a giant location
with all kinds of
overhead look at how big it was and yet
they survived how
they went direct to consumer they went
online that was the strategy
i call it the great digital pivot what
saved america
were companies that had passion and a
vision about a brand and
reached out to their customers right
through social media in every way they
could direct
and sold their products to them even
while they couldn't come to the retail
location
that's how tina kept this business alive
and that's the lesson we've learned here
today that's what i really wanted to
come here for
because when i walked through these
doors months ago to get my guitar
jonesified remember when i dropped well
i saw a beautiful space that was
basically empty
and i had to figure out how did they
stay alive now we know and this is a
lesson for
everybody a very important lesson
when you face adversity you gotta suck
it up and you gotta figure it out
and you have to do whatever you can to
stay alive if you like that video
wait did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe